here are a few things you should
probably be doing with your shirts when
wearing a white dress shirt undershirts
of the same color usually show through a
gray undershirt is typically less
visible as it more closely matches the
value of skin tone an easy way to get a
good sleeve roll is to pull the cuff up
like so and fold the sleeve over it here
Jack Kennedy did it this way so it's
probably good enough for you
simply shoving your shirt into your
pants can cause severe muffin-topping so
get a clean
tuck grab the bottom of the shirt and
fold the fabric back at the side seams
this hides extra fabric and is great for
shirts that are particularly wide or you
could just buy shirts that actually fit
and while we're on the subject of
tucking shirts with the longer curved
tails are designed to be tucked shirts
with flat bottoms are better suited for
leaving untucked and those little
sleeves on your collar are for collar
stays use them to achieve a more clean
formal look want to update an old shirt
you can turn a shirt collar into a band
collar simply cut off the collar here
you can also pull the stitching remove
the collar and resew it but you're
probably going to better
[Music]